Here's one more example of
a projective measurement.
This one is a measurement of two Qubits.
For this measurement
we have two projections and therefore, two possible
outcomes which are zero and one.
The projections are defined
in terms of the Bell states as you see right here.
The first projection is
onto the space spanned by the three symmetric Bell states and the second projection is
onto the one dimensional space
spanned by the Psi- state, which is the anti-symmetric one, or in other words the
one that gets multiplied
by a minus sign if we
perform a swap operation on the two Qubits.
We'll see later on in the series why this is an interesting measurement.
For now, it's just an example
that connects with something that we've seen before,
which is the Bell basis.
One final note on projective measurements is that anytime you have
a projective measurement, you can always implement that measurement
using unitary operations and
standard basis measurements.
For this particular example of
a measurement, for instance, we can build a quantum circuit that implements the measurement
as you see right here.
We imagine that the top
two Qubits are the Qubits that we're measuring with
this projective measurement and what we can do is
introduce a new Qubit
that starts off initialized
to the zero state. We perform a Hadamard gate
followed by a Fredkin gate, followed by another Hadamard gate,
and if we measure this bottom Qubit using a standard basis measurement, the effect will be exactly the same as if we've measured the top two Qubits
with the projective
measurement from this example.
We'll get exactly the same probabilities for the two outcomes and the effect that the measurement has on the top two Qubits
will be the same as well.
That's not at all obvious. An analysis is required to see that and that analysis isn't shown here.
As I've already suggested, we will take a closer look at
this particular measurement in a later lesson and for now
it's just meant as an example.
The important point to take away is that something like
this is always possible for any projective measurement, so we don't really gain
any additional capabilities
by introducing projective measurements, but it is a very useful concept and we will often speak
of projective measurements
as we continue on in the series. The last part of this lesson is on a few important limitations
of quantum information
and what we can do with quantum circuits.
The first limitation, which maybe isn't so much of a limitation as it is degeneracy, concerns the issue of global phases
that I mentioned a short time ago. Here's the definition of what we mean when we refer to a global phase.
If we have two quantum
state vectors, Psi and Phi, such that one of them is
equal to the other one multiplied by some complex number alpha,
then we say that the states
differ by a global phase or alternatively that they're equivalent up to a global phase.
Notice that because quantum state vectors have Euclidean norm equal to one, the only way that this
equation can possibly be true
is if the absolute value
of this complex number is equal to one, so alpha
must lie on the unit circle.
Let's imagine that we have
two quantum states like this that differ by a global phase and suppose that we measure the state Phi
with a standard basis measurement.
The probability to get any outcome A is given by this expression right here, and if we substitute
alpha times Psi for Phi,
which we can do because we're
assuming that they're equal, we obtain this probability.
And if we simplify using the fact that alpha lies in the
complex unit circle, we obtain this probability.
Remember that this is the probability that measuring Phi gives the outcome A, but now we see that
this is exactly the same as the probability that measuring
Psi gives the outcome A,
so there's absolutely
no difference whatsoever in the probabilities of different outcomes for the two states.
A similar argument tells us more generally that for any projective measurement, the probabilities are again identical.
So by measuring we can't
tell the difference between two states that
differ by a global phase, even in a statistical sense.
Finally, if we apply any unitary
operation to the state Phi, then again by substituting, what we will get is exactly
the same complex number alpha
multiplied to whatever we will get by applying the same unitary
operation to the state, Psi.
So the two states will still
differ by a global phase.
The bottom line is that the two states are completely indistinguishable, so there's really no
difference between them at all
in terms of what we could
possibly learn about them from performing unitary
operations and measurements and for this reason,
we consider these two
states to be equivalent or if you prefer, that these are just two possibly different
vector representations of
the same quantum state.
Like I said at the
start of the discussion, it's basically degeneracy
in how quantum states are described by quantum state vectors.
In any case, what this means is that we can
simply ignore global phases just like we did effectively when we describe standard
basis measurements